hi and welcome to today's webinar
leadership and competition striking the
right balance
i'm ryan price director of the stanford
executive program
and i'll be your moderator today we're
pleased to be in the classroom with
professor bill barnett
bill is the thomas m siebel professor of
business leadership
strategy and organizations he's also the
faculty director
of the stanford executive program which
we commonly refer to
as scp today you've joined us for a
webinar
and we would like to share other ways
you can engage with us
to stay informed on the latest
developments from the stanford graduate
school of business
we are charged with the mission of
changing lives
changing organizations and changing the
world
we believe we deliver on this mission
through the education
and development of leaders leaders like
you
our portfolio of residential and online
educational programs
help influential and dedicated leaders
to discover new perspectives
mindsets and frameworks that will help
them drive
impact and inspire innovation while it's
hard to describe our portfolio of
programs
succinctly innovative and inspiring
quickly come to mind
innovative you're at the heart of
silicon valley
you're at the forefront of cutting-edge
faculty research
that's shaping the future of modern
leadership and business
inspiring you're exposed to new ideas
people and ways of thinking you return
to work with a plan
and the tools to make an impact to share
one example from our portfolio
professor barnett and i work together on
our flagship executive education program
the stanford executive program or scp
scp is a six-week general management
program
that immerses you in stanford's unique
culture
of collaboration and creativity
the sap curriculum is designed to
strengthen your business fundamentals
and help you discover agile thoughtful
solutions
to the challenges and opportunities
faced by today's leaders
from design thinking and big data to
negotiation
financial engineering and strategic
management
you experience the very best the
stanford gsb
has to offer concentrated and customized
to meet the needs
and know-how of experienced leaders
the diverse and dynamic global leaders
in each cohort
add richness and depth to your
experience
we carefully curate each class selecting
participants from diverse industries
and unique experiences because we
believe
that's the only way true innovation
happens
we hope this webinar with professor
barnett gives you a taste of the
learning
available here at stanford we want to
hear from you
please submit your questions we'll
answer as many as possible either live
or
offline via email thank you bill for
being here with us today
well thank you very much ryan and thank
you for
coming to the webinar today we'll talk
for
a few minutes together about competition
and leadership
and as ryan said we'd love to hear
questions from you some people have
already sent in questions and we'll try
to get
to as many questions as we can
so i say competition and leadership and
a lot of different things come to mind
let me first say competition
is innate in the human experience
i remember years ago when
one of my sons who's now a full-blown
adult was just a kid a little guy
must have been five or six years old and
we had in
in town one of those soccer leagues
where
everybody's always supposed to be happy
during the game
and uh because they're five and six
years old so the idea is just let's go
out there and kick the ball around
and uh and of course there are just as
many adults as kids and so there's
you know it's quite a theatrical event
and some of the kids even at five or six
years old understood that in the game of
soccer as we call it in america
the the object of the game is to kick
the ball into a goal
and we had little goals set up and the
kids had little shirts on and so forth
and it's a smaller field than normal
beautiful california day
but we didn't want the kids to be
keeping score and
and tracking who was ahead or who was
behind because of the fact that
they're just little kids and we wanted
to make sure that they uh didn't get
overly competitive
um and so we're telling them the score
doesn't matter and
some of the kids had no clue what was
going on anyway so it wouldn't have
mattered if we were keeping score but
some of the kids including my son
james and his buddy jenner uh were
hankering to actually play a sport
it was sort of they were a little
frustrated by it
after a couple of saturdays on the third
saturday i remember
my buddy pete who was jenner's who's
jenner's dad
uh and i were we were the coaches and so
we noticed
that jenner and james were off at the
side and they had smuggled in
paper and crayons now they were only
five or six so they weren't really
they didn't have a lot of uh
ability to read and write and so forth
but but they knew how to keep score
so they were over there and they had
drawn up a score pad
and then every time one of the other
side they would keep scoring it was the
honest score if they were losing but
they just wanted to know
and i can remember now you know going
over and saying to pete well do we
do we take this away this league says
we're not supposed to keep score but
they're keeping score and we didn't have
the heart to take it away from them and
you know it's
at some level it's built in now some of
you right away
may be saying hang on barnett it's
cultural
well it turns out there's a lot of
literature on this
that competition happens in all human
societies
it's expression what we consider to be
the appropriate way to play out
competitions
that's what is cultural so there are
some
cultural contexts that would
shape competition differently in
different places if you've worked in
organizations
in different parts of the world you've
experienced this
where some kinds of competitions are
okay to have in some places and other
kinds in other places and
and so right away i want to say if
you're thinking it's not
innate it is but its expression
is what is culturally shaped and and
this is
uh what i think makes paying attention
to competition as a leader so important
because our organization and our
organization cultures are also part of
what shapes the way competition is
expressed
and i also i begin by talking about
competition as something that's
innate because i want to point out i
want to begin with the observation
that competition is happening all the
time among humans
even when they have not designed
a situation to facilitate competition
it's happening constantly
our psychology colleagues talk about
social comparison theory an idea that
goes way back to the 1950s and
the work of uh festinger and so forth
and
and uh no doubt you've been exposed to
some understanding of social comparison
theory social comparison theory
refers to this tendency that humans have
whenever we face uncertainty is to look
around at others
to find out where you stand
compared to others just to understand
what's considered appropriate and what's
considered not
appropriate in terms of levels of
of of excellence or behavior that's
where competition
uh comes in think about sometime in your
life when you
got a grade back on an exam back in the
old school days well the very first
thing you do
is find out what the other people around
you got on their tests
because you want to know where you stand
and as a long time professor i can tell
you you never just give people their
grades you give people their grades and
then you tell
them the distribution people have to
know where they stand
and you know the fact that that's a
relative group that
maybe that's not even the right group to
compare to that doesn't matter i just
want to know
where i stand
it's it's happening all the time it's
around us it shapes the decisions we
make
i remember when i was a young professor
i have been at stanford for a long time
and back when i was it was 1991
so i was in my early 30s i used to work
out on campus i don't do that anymore
i probably could do that now because we
have a lot of gymnasiums and all sorts
of facilities
but back then we just had one gym so if
you wanted to work out you went to this
particular gym and i will still i still
it is seared on my mind the day that i
was taking a shower when the entire
varsity football team of stanford
university came in and joined me
and that was not good for my self-esteem
now look nobody's comparing me to the
sanford football team
it's not like i have to worry about that
i just didn't want to be in the shower
with the stanford football team again so
now
i go off to the ymca in palo alto or i
can knock the other old guy
off a machine and be the big guy right
and it's
you know why should it matter well
because i'm a human
so it's constantly happening it's not
like you want to have a competition i'm
saying this because
if you work tonight to sit down with
someone have a conversation you go home
and you have a partner
spouse friend and you're having a
something to drink and
you get in a conversation you say that
there was something
was there something competitive going on
a lot of people say oh no no no
no our organization isn't competitive
hold on competition
is endemic it is innate it's there
among all humans now what they could be
referring to
is that their leaders have created a
context
that limits the expression of that
competition
and perhaps channels it in constructive
ways and we'll get to that in a few
minutes
but the potential for competition
the understanding that social comparison
is part of human existence
that goes on whenever there are people
that's always
that's always going on and therefore it
is very
important for you as a leader now that's
not now
of course folks tuned into this webinar
are at different levels in their career
some of you are quite advanced some of
you
are just emerging as a as a leader
others
perhaps you haven't yet moved into
leadership positions but you think about
that and it's
the kind of thing that uh you understand
could well be there in your future
competition
happens at the level of small groups at
the level of
whole departments of whole organizations
of industries and economies so it's
happening
everywhere so truly anyone in a
leadership position
has to be aware that competitive forces
are operating
we have a question from pedro
and he's asking when you're talking
about competition
is it always between humans or could you
be competing with something
that's not another person yeah
well that's interesting so um
clearly competition among humans is
where i went with my different stories
and and i often
when i'm trying to illustrate things
we'll tell stories at the level of
people
but very much so we understand that
competition takes place also among
uh groupings really almost arbitrary
groupings
there are some famous uh
experiments uh in fact they carried out
here at stanford university some years
ago
where simply dividing people into
groupings according to the color of
their
eyes made everyone involved in the
experiment
treat some people as out group and some
people as
in group simply based on something so
arbitrary as the color of their eyes
and these were people who were well
aware that they were all students they
were well aware that they were all part
of an experiment
and yet suddenly their their behavior
changed
and so you see the competition is
it's not just among people but it's
among the social construct of the group
and of course we see this in our
organizations all the time
once people know that someone is from
one department versus another one group
versus another
then the possibility of inter-group con
competition
uh kicks in at that point um
and pedro is a great question and we
will return to it
it'll come up in a in a few minutes
we're going to move to talking about
competition
among organizations and at that point
we'll return to your question but thanks
for that
uh ryan and uh
so as leaders if we're going to think
about
how to lead with competition in mind
there are some very specific
recommendations that i will give you
based on the research but
i'd like to explain those
recommendations
by first getting us to think through the
underlying
mechanisms that are at work when
competition is going on
there are basically two underlying
mechanisms
one i refer to as measuring up
so when you compete it gives you that
sense like i said
about the time when you were in school
and you wanted to know whether
missing uh five points on the test was
good or bad
you looked to others because you wanted
to know if you were measuring up
and so in that sense even if there isn't
an actual competition taking place
in the sense of a formalized tournament
simply knowing how others are doing
helps you to understand
where you measure up and so measuring up
is one way that
that competition is happening around us
all the time
it doesn't mean you want it to happen
it sometimes just happens i remember
having breakfast one morning and you'll
have to forgive me for all the stories
about kids but my wife and i have a lot
of kids so that
that's often my experiences and so but i
remember one morning
we're getting breakfast and my youngest
daughter uh lillian she was pretty young
at that point but she
was aware of of things going on around
by then
in terms of awards and so forth and you
know on the radio they announced the
nobel
prize winners during a certain season of
the
of the year and they announced you know
a nobel prize going to
uh one one of my colleagues here and at
stanford and
and lillian perked up and said hey dad
you know so and so won the nobel
prize this is a long pause and i could
just see it coming
she said you know dad isn't that the i
don't remember how many have been a lot
of stanford prizes that year is it like
the fifth prize this year whatever
number
i thought and she looked at me and i
could see what was coming she said dad
are you going to win the nobel prize
now i don't know if you have ever been
asked that question but you know at that
point i feel like you know no
i'm a failure right i mean it's it's
kind of the
the their jobs i could have had where i
wouldn't be asked that question
but once upon a time i got a job at this
institution and now these people are
running around you know at berkeley if
you want to get a good parking spot
one way to do it is you win the nobel
prize and then you get the nl
parking sticker which is the highly
valued so whenever i go to berkeley i
park in an nl spot because that's about
as close as i'm ever going to come
and you know am i measuring up i don't
know
i mean you could put yourself in a
different uh context and you'd feel like
you are measuring up
but it's that first mechanism it's not
like
you want to be in these contests but
they're all around us we're
constantly asking uh whether you're
whether you're measuring up uh you know
you you probably experienced it over the
weekend you
and your your partner or spouse
significant other we're at a party and
then somebody comes in
who looks like a movie star and then
suddenly everyone else is
uncomfortable well it's not like you're
in a competition for
in a in a beauty competition but the
fact is there you are
standing next to brad pitt and it just
is going to have an effect on you and so
you think about social comparison
the measuring up aspect is constantly
there
the second way the second mechanism is
scarcity
because of scarcity competition is
understood to exist even when we're not
making a social comparison
and so think about it that way the last
time you were in a meeting and you were
seen as a representative from a
representative
from your function maybe coming out of
marketing or coming out of strategy or
finance or operations
and somebody else is there from another
department
and there's a question about a budgetary
allocation should it go to your
department or should it go to their
department
right away you're realizing well my goal
is to get
that allocation and my argument will be
to say all the reasons why
my department should get that allocation
but you notice you you should actually
have done it the other way around if
what we cared about was the organization
we would say well let's talk about where
this allocation should go for the good
of the organization
and then after we've moved through the
logic we might conclude that in fact the
other person's department ought to get
that allocation
as much as we wish that's the way things
would go the understanding that there's
scarcity will typically lead people to
say
well first of all let me accumulate
resources for my department
and in fact for many people when they
take a position of leadership
being the rainmaker for their department
or group or function or they're part of
the organization is often seen as what
their primary responsibility is
that they should be bringing in
resources so that the
the rest of the men and women in the
organization in that part of the
organization can get their job done if
you're not bringing in resources
you're not doing doing your job well
bringing in resources
means winning in competitions
over scarce resources and so it's both
measuring up
making that comparison but also
getting a hold of resources in a world
of zero
sum trade-offs where what you get i
don't get
those are the two mechanisms that make
it so competition
is going on all the time
now you know the reason i bring up these
two mechanisms is that the
consequences of competition are best
understood once you
recognize that these mechanisms are
going on
and let's face it sometimes those
competitions are those
consequences of competition are great
when it comes to measuring up you want
to know where you stand so that you know
if you have to pick up your game
and also to know whether or not that's a
game you even think you ought to be
playing
i remember as a kid thinking that i'd be
a baseball player
fortunately there were contexts where i
could go be compared to others
so that i didn't waste much more time
going in that direction
than because that was not to be that was
not really an area where
where i was going to measure up and so
that's the good side of competition we
find out
who it is who who should be moving in a
particular direction and doing a certain
thing we know how to evaluate the
quality of what we do
and when we lack the ability to to to
measure up
we often get dysfunctional consequences
so you do want to have
competitions i remember i used to i used
to
get fried chicken from a chinese takeout
on the canterbury road in folkston
england right across the
road from the black bull inn at a
chinese takeout run by some indian
people who were actually a post office
now as you can imagine that probably
wasn't the best
fried chicken you were ever going to get
they called it maryland fried chicken i
am not sure
why they it had bananas thrown in the
batter too it was
disgusting as i think back on it but
there was no
they weren't involved in much of a
competition you can go to parts of
the united states where competitions and
seoul korea for that matter
where competitions over making good
fried chicken are fierce
and the survivors of those competitions
are amazing organizations
this one wasn't one of them so you do
want to have the measuring up the
measuring up
allows you to sort out quality
however because
measuring up is everywhere it can often
be
counterproductive you can often be in
situations with
people where the need to measure up
creates a tremendous amount of stress
where the human consequences of
constantly being evaluated are actually
bad for people
in terms of their their health our
colleagues in
uh in the sciences and in psychology
have documented this
um and where many of their behaviors
turn out to be counterproductive in
particular
the tendency to be risk averse if you
know you're going to be measured up
against the performance of others
will you risk ever failing what if you
take a course of action
that might have big possible returns for
your organization
but if it doesn't go well might cause
a failure will you be reluctant to do
that well that may depend on how much
pressure there is to measure up so we
have to be aware of the fact though
though we would love it if competition
always had
positive consequences it often has very
negative consequences
both for the human condition and for
the behavior of humans who live in fear
of
seeming to be a failure
and also with respect to scarcity and
zero-sum trade-offs
once again that can have a good
consequence
in the sense that it makes people do
their best
to justify having resources we don't
want to be budgeting
resources without people making a good
argument but on the other hand
many of the maladies that we see in
organizational life
where people are working for their own
good individually
or the good of their group and not the
good of the organization
come from the fact that there's scarcity
we would wish people would think
what is the the uh kind of budgetary
allocation that would be best for the
organization
but unfortunately knowing their scarcity
people become much more acquisitive in
organizations
and that's also a set of maladies and
because of those maladies
leaders are confronted with the
following situation
at work okay now
listen carefully to what i'm about to
say number one
competition is endemic and it's innate
in our lives at work so we know it's
going to be there
and then number two although it often
has good consequences
we know it often has incredibly
counterproductive consequences
both for human health for human health
and for our behavior in organizations
where we're either risk averse
or we're trying to amass resources even
when that's not good for the
organization
we have a number of questions coming in
around the idea
between competition and collaboration
and could you even compete to be good
collaborators
and how do you think about those two
attributes as a leader on a team
yeah that's a great point you know um
almost always you will hear people
academics especially
but people in general and consultancies
and so forth
talk about cooperation and uh
competition
almost as if they were um
uh opposing or polar opposites
so i love this question uh ryan because
um
it's much subtler than that the way that
we really see
competition and and cooperation or
collaboration happening in organizations
is that uh is is in a sense we
by working together are cooperating
which implies that we're pooling our
efforts in the same direction
and trying to be supportive of one
another which you would not think of as
as a competition
but we often pool our efforts in order
to compete in other words in order to do
better
and end up competing and while i i try
to
refrain from too many sports references
because
many of you may not be sports fans
please bear with me because sports is
the one place that really does
illustrate
this phenomenon uh sort of more
effectively than any other
obviously sports can be very competitive
it's the whole nature
of sports that they're set up to
theatrically demonstrate
a winner and a loser
but of course team sports will typically
have a set of fierce competitors who are
working together and
it is almost by definition a great
leader
who knows to align the
efforts of these fierce competitors so
they're not against one another
but for one another in the same
direction and it's up to the leader to
make sure
that those same behaviors and
passions that power the athlete to want
to compete with another team
are not turned against her teammates
if she turns them against her teammates
then you end up with a lot of the
counterproductive competition within the
team
and that's already built in if you're
the very best
player of a certain type by your very
nature
you will probably be getting more
playing time and the other one won't so
the the good coaches are not trying to
orchestrate more competition within the
team
they're in fact trying to mitigate
against it uh ryan so i i love that uh
i love that and in fact it leads me to
the first of my conclusions
that you should take away and so for
those of you who've been waiting for the
takeaways perk up
here they are number one don't
create competitions
at work so many times
well-meaning people in leadership
positions
will create increasing incentives to
compete or
increasing basically they'll orchestrate
competitions at all levels
in terms of performance evaluations that
are explicitly competitive
or in terms of other kinds of
competitions look competition already
exists in your organization
if you turn up the heat and have even
more competition than what is naturally
occurring
you can easily almost predictably
spill over into having the maladaptive
problems that can come from too much
competition
and then secondly create a culture
in your organization that works
against the negative
implications of competition so for
example
we talked about in the face of
uh scarcity uh or measuring up
of worrying about making a mistake and
so therefore being risk-averse
but you do need people to take the risk
of
trying new things at times and talking
about ideas that aren't fully proven
well in order to have that kind of
behavior
in a competitive world you'll want to
create a culture
that encourages taking
risks that are appropriate for your
organization
even though those might end up in
negative consequences
and so as a leader you're going in and
trying to work against
the natural tendency to be risk averse
that we see
coming out of the fact that competitions
for measuring up are constantly going
on around us or once again
if we think about creating a culture
where the norms
are to care about the organization when
it comes to resource allocation
rather than my group and it can be very
difficult to do that you can look at a
cross-functional team in one
organization
that performs very badly because of the
infighting
and that same cross-functional team in
an organization that has a culture
that works towards the betterment the
the collective understanding that we're
working for the betterment of the whole
organization
is going to have less of that infighting
so don't create competition do create a
culture that mitigates against the bad
sides
of competition
so what i'd like to do now so i know for
some of you who know the research i've
done you may be surprised
at what we've just talked about
because i have spent much of my career
doing work
on the benefits of competitions among
organizations
so-called red queen competition where
organizations competing with one another
make
uh the level of excellence and quality
in an industry
increase and therefore they themselves
become more competitive
and so to have me now come forward and
speak for a full half hour on all the
reasons
that competition inside organizations
is something that as a leader you want
to attenuate
and uh and and guard against the
negative consequences of may be
surprising to many of you
um and so now let's turn to that
question what about competition
among organizations among companies
among not-for-profits in parts of the in
the world those kinds of competitions
they happen as well what i think is so
interesting about competition among
organizations
is that we have the field of strategy
the field of strategy going way back
to the earliest days of competitor
analysis in the 1980s
was a field based on the uh
the single idea that organizations
should avoid
competing if you think about it
those of you who've had strategy classes
the very first thing that you learn is
that you want to avoid
competitors you want to make sure no
rivals are going to enter
you want to make sure if you have buyers
that they're weak you want to make sure
if you have suppliers that they're weak
and you want to make sure there are no
substitutes for what you do
in the world of strategy you will have
succeeded
when you were alone
a world where there's no competition to
worry about
well much of my early careers work was
documenting
that that idea that competition is bad
for organizations
is false well sure
in a world where you could be a
monopolist today and will forever be a
monopolist
there's an argument to be made for
staying a monopolist because
you'll never face any competition but in
a world where new competition is always
just around the corner
it turns out that competition
disciplines competition
teaches organizations that have competed
tend to compete even better going into
the future
i remember when reid hastings was just
starting netflix
and at that time i was
directing our strategy
executive program one of the various
programs that ryan
referred to that we have here at
stanford for helping executives
improve their leadership
skills and outlook and
we happen to have several participants
in that program
from a video rental company called
blockbuster
and we all were sitting together one
evening at the dinner when all the
executives are kind of talking about the
different ideas and it's just a
wonderful conversation environment
and i mentioned what what at that time
netflix was doing and of course now we
know what's happened but at that time
netflix was a risky move they were
mailing dvds
it was not obvious that they were
going to be a winner
and um but what was especially
interesting
is that neither netflix nor
blockbuster uh thought that in a
head-to-head competition
that netflix uh would end up uh
doing better now it turns out that the
approach that netflix took as we all
know was
evolved to be much more competitive than
the brick and mortar approach
our understanding of the world at that
time was that you needed brick and
mortar to have immediate access
to uh snow white or or cinderella in
order to get those home to the kids type
of thing or whatever movie you wanted to
watch
they were making most of their money on
late fees at the time so you would
drive down the street and every time you
saw the blockbuster you would feel
guilty because you'd remember that
cinderella's under the bed at home and
you got to get her back before you can
have snow
so no kids there's no snow white because
we got to find cinderella first
and and then every time you go in that
you'd have to pay large amounts of money
and late fees and never mind the fact
that none of that would happen with
netflix
it was only by directly competing that
we learned a
very different logic and would end up
preferring that one to the other one and
that competition would vastly
improve that industry for another
example if you have an iphone
you should be thankful that the android
ecosystem exists and if you have one of
the android phones a google phone or a
samsung or what have you
you should be thankful that the apple
ios
ecosystem exists because each of those
disciplines the other if your phone
can't navigate a map
the pressure from the competition from
the other side will
force them at some point to figure that
out and so forth
and in all these ways competition among
organizations is what
leads to that dynamic of ever improving
performance
we often call it red queen competition
because
there's a reference in biological
evolutionary theory
made by the great uh
now deceased biologist van valen back in
1973
who noticed that biological evolution
also had this quality
and he called it red queen competition
the references to lewis carroll through
the looking glass where alice
is having this dream and the queen says
the red
queen the playing card queen says to to
alice
uh something and then alice says but i'm
you know i'm running
as fast as i can but i am not moving
and the red queen says well you must be
from a slow world because here
we run just to stand still and that's
that's how it is in organizational life
organizations are improving all the time
but so are their rivals and so they're
feeling like
they're never ending up the monopolist
they never find that
that much talked about blue ocean where
they can
uh be alone but that's because those
things don't exist where there's a place
to make money
they're going to be rivals and those
rivals are actually good for
disciplining the organization
now i've made that argument among
organizations but i've made that
argument because organizations aren't
people
we discipline organizations if you don't
discipline
organizations they survive despite the
fact that they're peddling
maryland fried chicken right across from
the black bull inn on the foxton road
on the canterbury road in folkston at a
chinese takeout run by
indians at the their post office that
shouldn't exist
it only exists because of the lack of
competition
so every time you see an inefficiency in
organizational life
you should ask did somebody take some
kind of a strategy class where they
learned they should never compete
because that's leading their
organization to be put in a context
where it's underperforming i
i still stand in
awe of the story of pasco the great
korean steel company now today
those of you know the steel industry
know that pasco is a tremendous
innovator
but back after the korean war when pasco
was first being created
in south korea that country had a
labor advantage that told everyone that
if they were going to make steel
they should do it in a labor-intensive
way because they had a labor advantage
and that if they made steel with the
most modern technologies they would be
up against the great
german steel makers the great american
steel makers
etc instead
the leadership of pasco in korea backed
by
the government leaders in korea
bravely chose to move into
the highest technology levels of
production at pasco
they did that precisely because they
wanted to engage the competition
in order to raise the standards of
excellence among korean companies
it's no accident that that relatively
tiny country
has been one of the miracle economies
because they have had the courage
in their leadership to subject their
organizations
to competition but organizations aren't
people
so the maladies we talk about within
organizations
among people who compete of stress
of counterproductive behaviors that's
very different at the industrial level
so look where we stand
we typically we teach our leaders
to increase competition inside
organizations
but not to compete outside and i am
arguing for the very
opposite approach when it comes to your
organization
go out and compete that's where the
competition should be happening
but inside your organization facilitate
collaboration mitigate against
the maladies of too much competition
because your people have
inherent human pressures to compare
themselves to one another
to grapple over scarce resources and one
of your
primary responsibilities as a leader
is to put in place a context where the
counterproductive consequences
of competition are less common
now look i want to open it up to more
questions but uh
but before uh i do i'm i feel compelled
as the director of the stanford
executive program to put a plug in but
please don't sign out
okay because you were you were figuring
at some point barnett would go into his
pitch
i'm not saying you should come to
stanford
but i am saying you should pay attention
to the role of the leader that you
should take the role of the leader
seriously and of course you're thinking
but of course no no no
why did you get promoted why do we
promote people into their leadership
positions
typically because they did something in
a job
that they will stop doing after they
become a leader
i was speaking with someone who works at
a
pharmaceutical company just last week
here on campus and she had been promoted
into a leadership position
and was now here studying at stanford
leadership skills in executive education
but
she's a scientist she made her chops
doing great science
and stood out as a scientist so they
promoted her
well the trouble is as a leader in the
in this particular pharmaceutical
company
her she's no longer on the bench as a as
the scientists put it so she's not there
doing the
the genetics and and with the with the
white coat on
she's now going to meetings and talking
about budgetary allocations and working
across functional teams and making sure
that legal compliance and
regulatory affairs is up on the latest
developments and their innovations and
that their
new innovations are getting patented and
all those things that leaders care about
those weren't things that she learned
about
back when she was getting her phd and
becoming a scientist
and for every one of you you have a
story
and your story probably featured doing
something
reasonably well perhaps very well
and often that story does not include a
training
in understanding the tools you need as a
leader
so you need to invest in that and yes
here at stanford
we do have programs for you there are
other ways you can invest in those as
well
but don't neglect your education
as a leader
thank you thank you ryan you're welcome
we have a number of questions
um so one of the questions we're getting
a lot in different angles
is the relationship between competition
and diversity
and that's more looking inside the
organization which you were
talking about being a place to lessen
competition
but i wondered if you wanted to speak to
diversity
and competition yeah so thank you very
much
uh ryan and and you know the uh
i think the reason that the uh
the call for diversity in organizational
life
is so important is that we want to make
sure we're clear
about the criteria that are used
for advancing people in their careers
you know if you if you think about it uh
you know in a world where traditional
patterns
um which in in the united states would
mean uh
the hiring and promoting of white men
for example but where traditional
patterns
maintain themselves
we end up in a situation where we're not
allowing
large parts of the workforce the
opportunity
to go ahead and show that they're as
capable or even more capable than anyone
else at the things that they want to do
now we've seen that changing so much
across the
world that it it gladdens my heart
as an old guy i've seen quite a bit of
change
uh over the decades and
and each time you see the call for
greater diversity
having success you see more people being
given a chance
to be rewarded on the basis of merit
regardless of the superficial things
about them
like their sex uh or their race
uh or their religion or their national
origin and so forth
one of the things i love about
being at stanford as a as a professor
and
teaching over the years has is has been
to see
the increasing diversity among our
undergraduates among our graduate
students and among our faculty
uh and so when i look on the walls where
they'll have you know pictures of the
old faculty
it's a very homogeneous group because it
dates back to an
era where
there was less diversity in terms of
access to these opportunities and i'm
not trying to make it
please don't misunderstand me i'm not
trying to say all the problems in the
world have been solved with respect to
equal opportunity they have not they
absolutely have not
but that's what makes this such an
important question so i'm so glad it's
come up
uh here at stanford as uh as is the case
i think for
uh most of the great educational
institutions of the world
we care to get the very best and if we
get the very best
they will look different from one
another
and so if you have had a life
that has taken you through avenues that
are
non-traditional and you're wondering
maybe you're concerned that you might
not
fit in very well in stanford executive
education
that means you'll fit in great because
we do everything we can
to look for the most innovative the most
creative
participants in our executive education
we do have selective
educa executive education programs
especially
sep but we select on the basis
of the innovativeness and
experience that a person brings to the
table
and because of that we have a very
diverse
group it's it makes you
[Music]
it's amazing when you're teaching and
you see people
who are from every continent i uh
often over half of the people in the
room will be from outside of the united
states you
you see women you see men you see
all different races you see different
religions people dressed
sometimes in very traditional ways
people dressed in western ways you see
people of different sexual orientations
and
you see us all commonly trying to
understand
how organizations can function better
how the world can be made to be a better
place and it's incredibly inspiring so i
i i just have to say you know we talk
about competition
to me allowing for diversity and making
sure competition has healthy
consequences
are are exactly uh they are
they are two sides of the of the same
coin i remember
writing a paper back in the 90s
where
my co-author anne minor a wonderful
professor at the university of wisconsin
and i wrote this paper on competitions
inside organizations
and noted that if you
if you hire
a a more diverse workforce
but you don't promote allowing for
diversity
then you really lead to some terrible
counterproductive
uh consequences that what you really
want to do is allow for diversity
both in hiring and in promotion so that
merit is the criterion that is used for
advancement
and that leads by its very nature to a
more diverse
uh leadership team and a and a more
diverse organization throughout
thank you you bet we have another
question
around kind of this issue of competition
but one of the things i'm noticing in
the questions and that you've said is
there's also this factor of
accountability
so when you're looking internally and
you're thinking about merit
accountability is a way to demonstrate
how someone has
obtained a level of of merit or not
but could you speak to how internally
without competition
you would drive an organization to move
away from meritocracy
or infighting etc yes yes so
yeah that's a great question so of
course accountability is important for
we need to be able to make sure
that we're accountable not only that our
behaviors are appropriate
uh in terms of uh who's responsible for
a decision
um but also in terms of resource
allocation
so we have to make sure that our
resource allocations in organizations
are justified
and much of organizational life as we
all know
is spent laying out justifications for
why we spend money here
and not there or why we made this
decision and not that decision
and often these um
the drive to assure accountability
goes on as part of a a post-mortem
if you will that if you haven't heard
that expression sometimes we'll use it
in organizations to talk about sort of
after there's been an attempt to do
something maybe a new project or a
a new initiative of some kind
if it goes well but especially if it
doesn't go well we'll often say let's do
a post-mortem
and that's really sort of looking back
on what happened
and trying to account for
what decisions were made and how could
we do better the next time
so when a post-mortem and accountability
are being uh assured in a way that is
good for an organization
what we're doing is taking what we've
done learning from it
so that the next time around we'll do a
better job
now unfortunately one of the things that
often happens
is that the drive to assure
accountability
leads people if they're concerned
that they might end up suffering
unfairly
from some future post-mortem it leads
people
to be risk-averse to
to try to cover their bases to make sure
that they aren't going to be held
accountable for something that maybe
they couldn't control
and of course this is you know much the
the stuff of comedy about
organizational life of people who spend
more time
making sure they're not going to be
blamed for things
than they do actually trying to get the
job done
and so this is in fact exactly one of
these counterproductive consequences of
competition
if you turn up the competitive heat in
organizations
you don't get fiercer competitors you
get a lot more
covering of the rear end as people are
trying to make sure
that they're going to be safe um against
uh any kind of of possible
repercussions from some future
post-mortem
so what you would rather have precisely
by turning down the dial on the
intensity of competition
it makes our drive to
for accountability and to do
post-mortems much healthier
because now people see it as well you
know we didn't do well at something
let's learn from that understanding
that if part of that learning shows that
perhaps decisions they made weren't the
best
decisions and they would do it
differently next time that that's not
going to damage their careers
and this has to go past words by the way
this goes into the domain of action
because people are not stupid
and they know uh when you're not
walking the talk so if you if you want
to make a healthy context
for people to take risks at an
appropriate level
you have to make sure that people are
accountable but you have to do so in a
way
where they're not unduly suffering from
competitive comparisons with others
and by the way i should add the the
the research literature that i'm drawing
on here is is really
vast this is an area that has been
studied by social psychologists
by organizational behavior experts
by behavioral economists really across a
wide range of different disciplines
you you draw on to to reach these
conclusions
uh that i'm reaching and not everyone
would agree with me
there are some scholars and there are
certainly some organizations that really
want to double down on competition
but i think the arguments i'm making are
based on a good understanding
that competition is endemic in life
and then that therefore the job of the
leader is to create a context
where those competitions uh are less
counterproductive
now there's a i'd like to just say one
final thing ryan if you wouldn't mind
and then i'm going to turn it back over
to you
as you develop as a leader
if there was one thing i would want you
to do
is to see your job not as to be the
person who knows what needs to be done
you need to see your job as the person
who creates the context
within which others can be all that they
can be
you create a context when you're a
leader
inside your organization create a
context
where the forces of competition which of
course will be there
manifest in positive outcomes both for
the health
of your individual employees but also
for the performance of your organization
and i wish you all the best with that